well it appears that a letter has now
been received by the president here
in israel from yaya lapid the leader of
one of the
many opposition parties who have managed
they say now to
form a coalition government so this is
big news in israel a momentous day
uh not least because a new a new
president was um
was voted on but much much more
significant
two years of political deadlock four
elections in just
in in that period two-year period and
finally
it appears that there is a new dawn for
israel
uh there is uh a few words from ya lapid
in his letter to president rivlin he
says
the government will do everything it can
to unite every part of
israeli society after intense work on
behalf of all the citizens of israel
and the two-year-long political crisis
uh we
the various different parties have
informed president rivlin
that we are sick we are have succeeded
in forming a government so that sounds
doesn't it like a done deal
well it's not uh not yet um benjamin
netanyahu the
prime minister of this country for 12
years
and a figure who has been at the heart
of israeli politics and regional
politics
for more than three decades he served as
prime minister in the 1990s as well
he is a consummate um political survivor
he will do
everything he can over the coming days
to scupper
this deal how can he do that well
because
although tonight this new government has
been
announced these uh different and very
awkward coalition
members say that they will be able to
form a government
there is now a period of 10 days or so
before
a confidence vote in the knesset now
over the course of that 10 days
uh president prime minister netanyahu
and his party
will do all they can to chip away at
that majority to try and lure individual
members of the knesset
away from it it's very fragile because
it's made up
of so many different political political
groupings there are centrist parties
there are parties a little bit to the
left there are right-wing parties
and parties far to the right too indeed
the man who
will become prime minister if all this
works
is naftali bennett not the the man who
has sent that letter to the president
naftali bennett
is a former defense minister he is far
to the right of center
further to the right of president of
prime minister netanyahu
and yet he will be the prime minister
because the only way that
yaela lapid was able to get this
coalition together was to do deals and
say okay fine i'll stand back and i'll
let you naftali bennett be the prime
minister for a period
of two years so so it's a very very
awkward
uh coalition but i think tonight one
thing has been made clear by an image a
photograph
that has emerged in the last half an
hour a photograph
of three very very different politicians
it is yellow peed on the left
a centrist secular politician in the
middle
is naftali bennett a a hard-line
right-wing politician and on the right
uh is the leader of the islamist party
here in israel the arab israel one of
the arab israeli parties
three very very different men all united
against one thing benjamin netanyahu he
has managed to unite very very different
people
against him to push him out but as i say
the next 10 days
will be critical